[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'elle vient faire j'ai mes
étudiants inscrits à l'école de mad
la chambre et tous derniers étages c'est
pas j'adore
si je pouvais voyager dans le temps
j'aimerais avait aussi à londres
dans les années 60
la nuit dernière j'ai vu quelque chose
dans mes rêves
[Musique]
il y avait une fille
et vous êtes 110
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà
j'ai une sorte de dents
je vois des gens des endroits des choses
que personne ne voit
ici des gens s'approche au plus près de
leurs rêves
là
ce ne sont pas que des rêves
jack je veux pas faire ça tu crois que
tu peux partir quand on s'absente
je les ai vus en vrai
tu as vu quoi
[Musique]
est ce que vous croyez au fantôme
[Applaudissements]
de ce post est allé un meurtre hier soir
vous avez été témoin d'un meurtre mais
vous pensez que c'était une vision d'un
événement passé
qui l'a tué court toujours
il faut que je l'arrêtent
[Musique]
à
tous comptent aller où
je sais ce que j'ai fait un tas de
choses je vais te demander d'être un
petit peu plus précise que ça tu vaux
il est trop tard pour moi